mr president thank you very very much
for your leadership and for the efforts
of your entire team
um
i'm from way down here
where i'm sitting
we get to look across a vast hall
of people
and
i'm thinking about the different lives
that are out here
the extraordinary number of people
who've come together
here in glasgow but it isn't the two
weeks here
months
years for many
it is time to come together for future
generations in ways that none of us
really ever thought we might have an
opportunity to do
200 almost 200 countries
people from every walk of life
and we each have our own priorities for
sure
uh
as simon just said you know
there's a discomfort
well if it's a good negotiation
all the parties are uncomfortable
and this has been i think a good
negotiation
we
are seeking the shared goal of keeping
the earth's temperature at the level
that the world
scientists tell us we must do
and
yes there are things in this
text that every country here can come up
with that doesn't meet their
best desire
but
um
obviously
we know the old adage of negotiation you
can't let them perfect
be the enemy of the good
and and this is good
this is a powerful statement
i think there's an inclination for all
of us because these two weeks are long
to
have almost forgotten the first couple
of days
the power of all of our leaders being
here the promises the commitments that
were put on the table
and so
we in the united states are are really
excited
by the fact that this raises ambition on
a global basis
it sets standards by which we will
measure
it it asks everybody to be part of the
process
and
we have done
something significant on
not just mitigation but increasing
adaptation
resilience
scaling up adaptation finance
and moving forward on loss and damage as
tough as that's been previously
i want
to affirm to some of those of you have
been concerned that we look forward
to participating constructively in the
dialogue
on loss and damage and contributing to
its success
we've also
strongly supported inclusion elements
here that
will set long-term net zero ghg
strategies
and for our friend from gabon
who asked specifically that he have some
better assurance before he leaves here
regarding the attention adaptation
funding let me just make assurance at
least from our part and i think from our
close allies and friends
i can assure our friend from gabon and
from the other countries concerned
that every effort in the world will be
made there's a commitment that is real
to double adaptation finance
including our announcement uh that we
will
double our own
and work
in other ways to deal with the challenge
of adaptation
so we are we are poised
we are poised to make a remarkable step
here
uh to
reflect the best outcome possible on the
paris agreement itself on the rule book
on things like common time frames and
ndcs and article six guidance all of
which are tough
but where everybody has approached this
with a remarkable spirit
of compromise and of global intent
so i would simply say in in sort of
thinking about the next
moments here
uh
this
potential agreement which we're poised
to accept and make real
uh is a
very important step in the right
direction
as i think about it
the agreement
the agreement that
china and the united states came to the
other day
i know we both talked about this hope it
shows that even in a world where there
are conflict and
and competition and differences between
nations that
this issue
can bring people together in an effort
to try to reach above those
and to find the way forward
i closed this by saying to everybody not
everybody in public life i've been in
public life a long time
not everyone in public life and we are
all in public life whether you're there
permanently or temporarily in this
endeavor but not everyone gets to make
choices about life and death
not everyone gets to make choices
that actually affect an entire
planet we here are privileged today to
do exactly that
so
i hope before long
we are going to ratify this accept this
text
initiate a critical set of choices for
all citizens around the world for this
decade
so that we can in fact
that we can in fact
guarantee to our children our
grandchildren to the next generations
that we did our job
and i'm proud to be here and be part of
it thank you